[Música]
[Aplausos]
estou muito feliz de estar aqui mas
muito feliz de estar aqui sabe a
felicidade que a gente não cabe dentro
da gente
se tudo der certo vocês vão daí sentia
essa felicidade também fez conseguem
perceber que eu estou muito feliz porque
se vocês perceberam que estou muito
feliz essa felicidade vai ter cumprido o
papel dela não só pra mim mas para vocês
também
e se tem uma coisa que eu acredito na
vida e amo amo é empatia
a gente é feito pra trocar todo o nosso
corpo é feito de sensores que fazem com
que a gente consiga perceber o que a
outra pessoa está sentindo sentiu e se
relacionar com ela as crianças pequenas
fazem isso muito bem não é por que será
que a gente vai desaprendendo quando a
gente vai ficando adulto que a gente
talvez vá assim engessando eu sempre fui
apaixonada pelo corpo e por essas
potencialidades
por outro lado eu tenho a sorte de ter
nascido numa família de artistas
eu sou filha de poeta meu pai e de uma
pintura
eu brinco quando fui fazer engenharia e
quase foi deserdado mas eu continuei
sempre ligada à arte dançando e tendo
uma idéias relacionadas a corpo ea esse
potencial de arte então o que eu quero
fazer aqui é mostrar pra vocês como
vocês podem usar essa visão artística
esse olhar artístico para ficarem mais
inteligente mais inteligentes e
emocionalmente é claro mas mesmo mais
inteligente racionalmente
hoje em dia está provado que a gente não
faz uma coisa só não é só um lado do
cérebro a gente interage essas duas
coisas
então a gente vai passar por um caminho
agora a primeira coisa que eu preciso é
que vocês percebam que concordem comigo
o que todo mundo dessa sala tem a
potencialidade de ser melhor do que é
hoje
você concorda todo mundo todo mundo
dessas salas têm a potencialidade de ser
melhor do que é hoje nesse minuto e o
seu operacionalizador no mundo é o seu
corpo certo quando eu comecei a
trabalhar dando aula
a família também é de professores toda
ela
quando eu comecei a trabalhar dando aula
eu vi algumas daquelas pessoas
assim né será que a pessoa percebe que
com essa rigidez
ela vai ter mais dificuldade de aprender
e às vezes não eu vi gente fala assim eu
não estou com raiva
então a gente tem mais potencialidade no
corpo do que a gente está acostumado a
ter ea pensar ea gente hoje em dia neste
cotidiano líquido
a gente quando tem tempo de estar com a
gente às vezes está em outro lugar não é
quantas vezes eu estive treinando um
passo de balé esperando o elevador
parecia maluca mas olha que coisa doida
você parecer maluca porque você está
fazendo um movimento que seu corpo quer
te fazendo mal pra ninguém
se eu resolver eu vou andar no meio da
rua sim aquela alegria às pessoas vão
ser doida
vocês já ouviram hoje que sedou deve ser
bom porque eu vou deixar a pessoa me
restringi desse jeito eu daquela hora
não estou fazendo mal para ninguém
a verdade é que a gente tem mais
potencialidade no corpo do que a gente
imagina então se já pensaram que tem
cinco jeitos diferentes de bater palma
bateram palmas e já tem 51 é sagrado
considerado sagrado em muitos lugares no
mundo tem gente que bate palma assim
querem bater pra ver como é que você vai
é o seu primeiro jeito nessa junção pra
mim também mesmo quem está em casa são
exercícios podem tentar muita gente bate
palma assim tem gente que bate palma sim
tem gente que bate palma com dois dedos
só tem gente que bati com as costas da
mão sempre achei curioso isso ea sagrada
vamos ver se ela vai sair agora se chama
catira é como
a gente fizesse a palma da mão ficaste
tadim qual o couro de tamborim e aí ó
estão ouvindo que são sites como se
fosse um estalinho vocês todos têm isso
se você tiver que dizer assim eu sou o
cara eu sou aquela pessoa que vai bater
a onde no seu corpo
henry sair todo mundo no peito porque
você vai bater no peito porque sou maior
caixa acústica tão só nisso e você ainda
por cima cresce e fica grandão a gente
tem outra na boca eu já sei que não
posso pegar esse lado que o microfone
então ok ok também tem uma caixa
acústica muito boa e uma caixa acústica
que a gente não percebe que tem mas é
legal pelo menos eu acho legal quando
você instala o dedo
tem gente que não consegue mas quem
consegue treinou na infância acabou
fazendo isso certo você faz uma caixa
acústica aqui ó
sem essa caixa acústica nenhum som cef
ea gente faz e assim nem percebe que
está criando uma caixa acústica então eu
fui aquela criatura que deu trabalho
para comer ea mãe tá aqui não deixa
mentir
tem gente da família que ainda se
vangloria de conseguir me alimentar
mas eu ficava e ainda fico curioso de
feijão na boca pra lá na boca pra cá o
coisa deliciosa é lisinho a escola que
chamou ele explode na boca aquele
creminho eu sempre adorei essa sensação
e por que eu não posso ficar lá
brincando com a minha sensação não está
fazendo mal para ninguém
eu não estou fazendo com que a pessoa na
minha frente tem que fazer isso também
mas que é uma delícia é sabe quando
estiverem com muita sede a minha
sugestão é que você em vez de pegar e
nem pensar
a água entrando quando você tá com sede
é uma das sensações mais deliciosas que
a gente tem um raio x que foi discípulo
de freud depois acabou obrigando foi até
expulso da academia mas ele trabalhou
muito com o corpo pesquisou muito e
perguntaram para raios que quer o corpo
pra ele sabe qual foi a resposta o corpo
como uma festa e ele é
nem estou falando de namorar ele é uma
certa própria é uma festa se você se
permite experimentar e o mais legal
dessa festa é que ela pode incluir
outras pessoas se você tiver mais
consciência do seu próprio corpo também
a tal maneira de ficar inteligente tem a
ver com você se perceber a gente às
vezes esquece que a gente tem alguns
pedacinhos tem gente que não tem mais
condição de separar um dedinho do outro
só sabe levantar os 4 fiscal olho de
cada vez
brincar com a pálpebra do olho é super
gostosinha quando ele encosta assim na
pele o meu convite que vocês usem seus
tempos que o banco de ter que esperar
para escolher que está um pedacinho cada
vez o dia da orelha esquerda
hoje a orelha esquerda que eu vou
perceber hoje é o joelho essa pele
lisinha aqui de trás porque porque
quando a gente descobre um pedaço maior
da gente ea gente entende melhor a gente
cria conexão neural para usar aquele
pedaço
na verdade a gente ainda por cima tem a
possibilidade de usar o que a gente
aprendeu corporalmente numa área da vida
e aplicar em outra
eu tenho uma história curiosa em relação
a isso porque eu sempre dancei
eu amo dança que falam e cada vez tem um
ritmo novo que eu quero me desafiar
e aí eu tenho uma amiga muito querida
que me chamou pra ir aprender jiu jitsu
na verdade fui vê lo treinar e achei
aquilo legal eu vou tentar apaixonei
comecei a fazer jiu jitsu e dizer para
as pessoas que tenham dito pra mim era
parecido com dança de salão e eles
diziam que era doida que a gente já sabe
que é bom
então por que pra mim é a mesma coisa
porque o que eu tinha habilidade na
dança de salão tenho é conseguir ler o
que o cavaleiro que é que eu faço porque
sou dama e rapidamente responder ainda
por cima enfeitando ensina dança de
salão o cavaleiro tá lá pra me ajudar
em compensação no jiu jitsu é a mesma
coisa tem que ler o sinal do outro tem o
que responder rápido só que ele está lá
profissionalizar e quanto mais flexível
for em ambos vai ser bom então isso já
não é um exemplo
de empatia eu já não podemos só o meu
corpo eu já tô lendo o corpo das pessoas
também que as pesquisas todas mostram
que isso lê o corpo do outro é mais
rápido até do que raciocinar sobre essa
pessoa
então eu queria que vocês quiserem só
uma experiência breve comigo pode
levantavam assim por favor só levantarão
quetinhos aí então eu vou pedir pra
vocês por gentileza levantarem o seu
polegar e agora olhem pro lado quem de
fato levantou o polegar ou indicador que
foi um erro pedir isso funciona
isso funciona sempre a gente desde
criança aprende a espelhar o outro e
sentindo o nosso próprio corpo o que o
outro está sentindo porque é esse
espelhamento que vai garantir a gente
ter boa empatia e o espelhamento
funciona mais rápido do que o raciocínio
então se eu conseguir usar
intuitivamente o meu espelhamento eu
ganho um elemento a mais de decisão que
é super importante mas eu não consigo
fazer isso se eu não conseguir prestar
atenção na atitude corporal do outro com
algum grau de sutilezas
nós somos humanos têm uma série que se
chama light on me que talvez vocês
tenham visto que é muito interessante de
pesquisa de um psicólogo que chama
poética psiquiatra na verdade e ele fala
de expressões de como que a gente
consegue todo mundo regá-lo olho quando
está surpreso porque a gente regalo
julho
vocês sabem porque eu preciso ver melhor
a situação pensar bem se eu estou
surpresa porque 1 e conseguiu enxergar
aquela situação direito e eu agora
preciso de um pouco melhor
então ea arte a arte é uma das melhores
ferramentas que existem para a gente
ganhar novas possibilidades
o alan de botton filósofo criou um livro
recentemente falando sobre a arte como
terapia de 17 funções que a arte pode
ter para ajudar a gente a semi
em um outro autor chama clapton inglês
que criou um livro que a inteligência
está no corpo
não é assim que a gente tem um chapão
aqui no alto da cabeça que manda o corpo
fazer as coisas não é a gente tem corpos
que sabem fazer as coisas e quando a
gente estava indeciso gente acessa o
nosso cérebro eu sei que é diferente do
que a gente acredita mas pensa em seu
corpo não sabe algumas coisas sozinho às
vezes a gente não sabe um telefone mas o
seu deus sabe se escala
quantas vezes eu estava tocando piano
quando chegava no final foi como eu
posso executar essa música se eu não
lembro de nada do que eu fiz
então já não era o meu cérebro
raciocinando o nosso corpo tem ótimas
possibilidades que ele já aprendeu a
fazer isso é ótimo por um lado mais
difícil pelo outro porque quando eu
quero fazer diferente do que eu já faço
só se desafiar o meu corpo e de novas
possibilidades de lucro pra ele tem que
criar novos circuitos então eu preciso
criar novas experimentações quer ver uma
muito simples
esse processo eu falei pra vocês de
comer e se deliciar comendo pra muita
gente é dificílimo
mesmo que a pessoa a dora que o que está
comendo a mandar duas mordidas engole
tentem dar a décima 15ª mordida
duvido porque você já tá tudo
automatizado no processo que às vezes
você se atrapalhem conseguir manter a
comida sendo ainda degustado tentem e
esse é o meu convite que vocês olhem
cadê a visão artística a visão artística
essa possibilidade de olhar o mundo com
beleza olhar o mundo com ele ainda
melhor do que ele é todo dia
outro dia eu estava aqui na barra
clicado por minha cabeça cheia de coisa
pra fazer carro passando pra tudo quanto
é lado
aí eu passei aqui perto era um pedacinho
menor do que esse palco de grama e eles
estavam cortando a grama mas subiu o
cheiro delicioso aquele cheiro de grama
molhada nossa ganhei o dia por que eu
fiquei me lembrando desse cheiro da
a sensação ea ferramenta que eu vou
sugerir que vocês usem para melhorar sua
própria estada nesse corpo aqui é que
vocês procurem ver o belo sabe qual é o
exercício tentar no final do dia
lembrar de 10 coisas lindas 10 o melhor
antídoto que eu conheço que possa
oferecer pra vocês por experiência
contra esse pessimismo que às vezes pega
a gente é ver o belo é ver que tem gente
que está aqui que tá querendo fazer
melhor
mesmo que essas mesmas pessoas que um
dia que estejam mais animados se eu
consigo ver o belo e eu já sei que estou
atrás do belo
o meu corpo inteiro responde ao belo
porque ele sabe fazer isso é só uma
questão de ajustar o olhar e como eu
agora sei que eu tenho que chegar no 10º
dedo
adivinha eu já passa o dia
peraí que eu tô ruinzinha hoje ainda
todo o terceiro quarto deu preciso
enxergar mais coisa bonita e talvez eu
possa ligar para aquele amigo que tem a
voz mais agradável ou colocar uma música
linda pra tocar
se vocês colocarem mais olhar pro belo
na vida de todos vocês vocês terão corpo
de melhores mais leves e normalmente
isso atrai leveza e boas possibilidade
também
quando eu me graduei no doutorado pensa
bem e que coisa mental
eu terminei o doutor estava nervosa para
fazer aquela situação e os meus pais me
presentearam com o quadro que eu nem
lembrava que tinha pintado quando eu
tinha 17 anos com os seguintes dizeres
pra você nunca se esquecer que o que
vale na vida é a arte
eu sou muito grata e emocionei
eu sou muito grata por isso e por essa
possibilidade de trazer esse olhar para
a vida
recentemente estava em los angeles de um
congresso e curiosidade se vocês
quiserem ou não eu fui fazer
a ação de uma técnica didática ligada à
percussão corporal que eu tinha
desenvolvido pra ensinar melhoria de
comportamento para os meus alunos está
não me chamaram para participar de um
grupo da universidade de liverpool
replicar uma técnica na noruega sai
publicada num livro agora olha só que
legal com arte e curioso foi apresentar
o relato disso no ano seguinte entrei
num carro que eu tinha chamado pelo meu
aplicativo ea pessoa pedir pra parcial
só tinha um dia então escolhi o nome da
praia mais famosa no lugar
entrei no carro ea pessoa você vai pra
essa praia a motorista era ar motorista
que já tinha um nome que eu achei
curioso porque tinha a ver com yoga eu
pratico yoga algum tempo e eu vou sim
mas você gosta de arte a pessoa nunca
tinha visto na vida tá bom no meu perfil
no aplicativo não tem nada
você gosta de arte porque você não vai
para o museu de arte de los angeles é
ótimo eu fiquei assim olhando eleta é um
doido é não é maravilhoso começou a me
contar as coleções
eu acho que em outros tempos em outras
épocas eu talvez tivesse ficado
preocupada a pessoa é doida mas hoje
olha assim que legal que ela por algum
motivo ou intuição em alguma coisa em
mim ela leu o que eu gosto de arte que é
verdade é verdade eu vou-me preferia
estar num museu e acabei convidando o
motorista para dançar comigo já que
estava chegando a hora do almoço a gente
almoçou junto e ela me contando as
histórias o passeio museu quando eu saí
do museu olha eu estou aqui por perto eu
posso te buscar se você quiser e me
levou pro café gratidão comida
vegetariana da melhor qualidade
e olha esse estudo a empatia eu não sei
o que seria porque ela continua sendo
minha amiga eu acho que ela continua
torcendo por mim ela pediu por favor na
hora que estiver legendado em inglês
deixou saber e eu espero que ela e agora
vocês
percebo recebo esse poder
eu tenho eu não posso fazer mais do que
deixar o meu coração derramado aqui e eu
espero que vocês tenham sentido isso
também que vocês pensem no corpo de
vocês como vocês sentiram isso agora por
exemplo será que você está na melhor
posição sentado nesse exato minuto para
receber trocar com o meu coração ou pra
fazer e colocar em prática as coisas que
vocês querem do ted
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]